[Music]
hi I'm Giga can this is every framer so
in my previous video where I picked out
and broke down a few examples of
brilliant flights and anime a number of
you commented and I'm sure many more of
you thought that I only picked the
Naruto fights simply because of the
sponsor of that video and you know that
kind of hurt my feelings implying that
you'd think I'd have my opinion swayed
just because someone was paying me for
it
which is exactly why you can watch all
of Naruto and crunch water comes flashy
animator I'm kidding I'm kidding this
message has been sponsored and approved
by salt do you like being salty then
please be sure to show your continued
support for my videos by being salty now
plenty of examples were suggested the
fights that carry more emotional weights
behind them and while I agree most of
the fights end up being more emotional
thanks to a better plot build-up I feel
like the retired some fights that
execute storytelling even better in
their scenes alone so let me explain to
you why on a technical level Naruto has
at least two examples of some of the
best storytelling to ever come out of an
anime fight no this is not [ __ ]
satire
[Music]
but yes they also have some very [ __ ]
fights now I mainly talked about the
Naruto Sasuke fight in the video but the
one fight that almost took that spot was
Kakashi and obito's fight that came
before which does some aspects even
better than the latter fights but just
missed out as it was shorter and wasn't
as complete the story you may be
thinking well who [ __ ] cares how well
a fight tells a story it's just two
beeps beating the [ __ ] out of each other
can't you just appreciate a fight for
that well what I have to say to that is
a even if you don't realize it
every bite tells a story every fight has
a reason and emotions behind it even if
in most cases it's just a very simple
story like our main spying mate makeyou
Stein may I'll [ __ ] you up may I'll [ __ ]
you up like a [ __ ] your mum when my mom
saw slag your mom's slag
man these two fights the story is very
similar to old friends fighting each
other to defend their ideals and it just
so happens that their beliefs are so
strong that they are willing to fight to
the death for it and the way they
portrayed this story with minimal
dialogue is what sets them apart from
most other anime fights to illustrate
what I'm talking about then we take an
example of another fight that I have
really loved Yuko versus Satsuki's first
duel and kill the kill now just from
these scenes alone see how much you can
tell about the story the emotions and
the thoughts of the characters where the
fighters are even talking to each other
[Music]
poster this seemed done without any
dialogue
[Music]
okay you may think I'm being a little
unfair to use a flight whose main
selling point is the spectacle and don't
get me wrong I absolutely love this
fight but in terms of being able to
portray the story behind a fight the
characters thoughts and emotions I feel
that the latter fight has a much greater
impact even though there's no dialogue
it's much quieter and that it's from
[ __ ] Naruto the way the fight
juxtaposes the two fighters current and
younger selves among this beautifully
choreographed exchange gives us a better
sense of what's going on along with
their history these are two fighters
communicating purely through their fists
and we know what they are saying without
them actually saying anything and to cap
it off look how they show us how Evita
rejected the ideals of his former
younger self to get where he is now this
goes beyond just being a brilliant fight
this is brilliant visual storytelling
and the Naruto Sasuke fight borrows lots
of the same beats from this as it does
well to show the communication to people
can have with their fists as opposed to
their words by this point in the series
the final epic save the world battle has
already been done and dusted and there's
nothing really a stake except for their
own ideologies in the larger picture
this fight is actually far less
important but at the same time that's
why it works as a story as the entire
purpose of this fight is to bring
closure to both their character arcs and
that's exactly how it plays out the
start of the fight involved with a
complete lack of music to help emphasize
that this brawl is about these two guys
communicating with each other and not
the larger plot by this point they both
have such a deep understanding of how
each other thinks and feels that there
is no longer any need for words I
briefly mentioned this my fight video
but we are even subtly shown how much
they understand each other in the fight
throughout the whole series we see how
reliant Naruto is on his shadow clone
jutsu
like he's that one can't playing a
fighting game he only knows that one
opie move and keep spamming it to
victory so with that in mind look on
Naruto always immediately resourced to
trying to get off the shadow clone hand
sign and house Sasuke is very aware and
consciously reacts and stops him from
doing so
Naruto tries this a whole four times
before succeeding and abetting a bunch
you wouldn't have even noticed this on
your first viewing as it's not something
that's really highlighted but it's
subtle details like this that shows that
a lot of thought has been put into the
character actions in this fight the
middle of the fight is a flashy
extension showing how far both guys have
come since childhood and that despite
all this time the relationship has not
changed that much they've just found
bigger and more powerful ways to bicker
with one another about their beliefs but
the message can't get any pure as when
the fights just live boulders into the
fist fight as I said it's incredibly
intense and chock full of emotion and
it's the direction that makes it feel so
gritty and real teeth are knocked out
blood is [ __ ] spilled everywhere [ __ ]
man this fights over aww that just add
some crowd noises make it a vertical
shot and [ __ ] boy it's now become a
worldstar video all this leads up to one
of my favorite shots of the entire
franchise this one and a half minute
long unbroken shot just slowly panning
in closer to the two of them still
brawling out till sundown with hardly
enough energy left to throw a punch
you don't need words to describe how
both of them feel both physically and
mentally and long judges emphasizes the
fatigue as it feels just exhausting
watching it but while the fight does
great we'll trade these emotions and
story the reason I picked it over
Kakashi vs. Obito is that it does well
to end stories - firstly check out this
beautiful at a moment between Naruto and
Kurama they really came out nowhere
[Music]
this little fist bump that you saw
manages to conclude the character arcs
between these two characters perfectly
as we've seen throughout the series
Kurama transforms from this terrifying
beast that would have ripped Naruto
apart - a grouchy old Fox - just full
[ __ ] cinder a by the end I mean screw
Naruto Hinata Naruto Sakura even Naruto
Sasuke this is the real [ __ ] ship of
the series I'm the one who's been inside
you this entire time oh oh god please
stop saying it like that this fist-bump
manager seemed caps late how their
relationship has evolved over time with
just such a simple beautiful action and
the best part is this amazing little
moment wasn't even in the manga it's
entirely an anime only moment that
manages to build on what we know about
the characters this all builds up to the
ending of the fights as while it might
just seem like a normal cliched final
clash to end the fight this one contains
so much more than that aside from the
obvious Scrolls through their characters
through the ages we see the hands of
different people helping power their
attacks with Naruto starting off with
Jiraiya and then everyone else close to
him and for Sasuke we see the slight
glimpse of a hand which is probably his
brothers and this subtle detail
perfectly encapsulates what both
characters are about Naruto's driving
force throughout the entire series has
been the desire to be accepted by
everyone and now that he's achieved it
that's what he's fighting for while for
Sasuke though he'd like to think that
he's doing this all for himself has been
driven by his brother's experience this
final clash doesn't just symbolize the
end of the fight but it perfectly caps
off the journey both characters have
taken to get to this point and the
conflict of ideology which this fight
was all about again this is beyond just
a brilliant fight this is brilliant
visual storytelling and these two fights
showcase some of the best examples of
something the Rueter is quite
universally famous for not doing
subtlety it's not where the scenes tells
us that makes them so good but it's what
it lets us discern for ourselves and
what I find amazing is how they manage
to sum up so many emotions so many
thoughts and even finish up character
arcs with min more dialogue exchanged
between the characters this takes me to
the biggest thing holding back these
fights which aren't even the fight
themselves but the build-up to the
fights see despite everything I've said
I'm sure the majority of you will still
regard your favorite Naruto fight either
Rock Lee versus Gaara or even the first
Naruto Sasuke fight and rightly so as a
simple reasons that is because we are
more emotionally attached to those
fights the problem with these ones set
the poor
character arts building up to these
events were so badly done the bun time
the fights happened the majority of us
had already given up in the series or
just dropped two entirely Obito turned
out to be just a rather disposable
villain all things said and done and
Sasuke's character art was horrible
his journey throughout the series was
all over the [ __ ] place and I'd be
doubtful to find many people who
genuinely think that Sasuke wasn't a
laughably bad planned-out character it's
the motivation of these characters are
the question well rather than fights
themselves we are less invested in these
fights than we ever were with our
favorite fights and other anime series
or even previous Naruto fights despite
how brilliantly executed these are a
great example of how important it is to
have a proper build up the fights is in
one piece see on a technical level a lot
of one-piece fights don't live that
impressive compared to some of its shown
in competitors but it's a masterclass or
getting us to truly care about what is
happening which is why they feel so epic
the fights themselves are just an
extension of the emotion and the story
that have been built up and it does it
so well that can make us genuinely
invested and care about characters that
look like this like this which is why
even though these are two fights have
some of the best examples of
storytelling
they've been largely overlooked by the
greater anime community despite being
executed so damn impressively
in fact I go so far to say that had the
characters been built up better and the
audience were more emotionally attached
these would definitely go down as some
of the greatest fights in anime history
because god damn these are just
brilliantly directed scenes in general
regardless of it being a fight or not
and that's the other reason I wanted to
make this video
I feel like Shonen anime can get a bum
rap simply because it's shown in and you
know sometimes understandable as the
community can be toxic there's a lot of
crap and these are only two great scenes
in oh god maybe down the board agent be
a faster way out so that doesn't mean
that Shonen can't have equally
brilliantly directed sequences that
deserve praise as much as any other
mature multi-layered anime behind all
the screaming 14-year olds that can
actually be merits behind some of these
moments containing your favorite edge
Lord characters just leave the secrets
shown and toys like me to wade through
the hundreds of episodes so I can find
that one moment where I can go see you
guys
punching people in the face can be art
too
hey guys if you enjoyed this video then
be sure to check out my previous flight
video where I talk about a bunch of
other great anime flights as well also
if you like to see more content from me
that you consider supports me on patreon
or so you may have now heard that
YouTube favors content that gets more
like so please like the video I'm
kidding just like you if you just like
the video I don't care anyway that's it
for me I've been Giga and I'll see you
all next time